foreign
once again so I think I've talked before
probably on multiple occasions about my
ambivalence toward most found footage
movies like I said I like you know a
good smattering of them but it's not
usually my go-to genre
so I gotta say for the life of me I
can't remember why exactly I had this
particular movie on my radar to review
and why exactly like I placed it on my
schedule because usually I keep a
schedule like I do a schedule about a
month in advance sometimes I'd Shuffle
the movies out like if they leave a
particular streaming service or
something like that but this had been on
there since the beginning of the month
so why did I pick this movie I can't
actually remember it it was probably
because a somebody recommended it which
is possible uh B it was about the
diatlov pass incident uh you know which
is a very famous unsolved mystery that
we did a show about a really long time
ago I think like back in the episode
like the 20s or something like that not
in the 1920s but like in the episode
number 20s and or it was free on a
streaming service somewhere
now since that third thing turned out
not to be the case I mean I could have
sworn that I saw it free on 2B or
something but then when I went to watch
it I couldn't find it on there like
under any of its titles so I ended up
actually paying a couple bucks to rent
it on Amazon Prime which whatever no big
deal
um so I'm figuring maybe it was one of
the first two reasons although I did see
another video somebody that reviewed it
like a year or two ago and then they
said it was on 2B but when they searched
for it they couldn't find it like they
only found it when they scrolled through
but I was like ain't no one got time for
that so I was like I'll just pay three
dollars and like [ __ ] rent the thing
now uh so even though I can't really
remember like why I chose this movie
particularly
um this was actually a pretty okay like
found footage flick now it does take a
lot of liberties with the true story
that inspired it and the CGI effects in
it were not awesome let's put it that
way but it kind of had a neat little
twist at the end that actually made me
like it more after I watch it watched it
than I did while I was actually watching
it like if that makes any sense so
interestingly uh Devil's Pass is not
some like cheap Jack found footage
situation that was made by a bunch of
amateurs with cell phones or anything
like that it was actually directed by
Renny Harlan who you know he's not a
massive Superstar auteur or anything
like that but he does have some kind of
big blockbuster movies like under his
belt he did Nightmare on Elm Street 4
for example he did die hard 2. he did a
cliffhanger with Sylvester Stallone he
did deep blue sea lots of other things
like that uh so this movie Devil's past
came out in 2013 and is also known under
the alternate title the diatlov pass
incident now
um I'm actually not sure how much it
costs to shoot this movie uh doesn't
really say on Wikipedia but I will give
props to Renny Harlan for actually
filming it as far as I can determine uh
in actually Northern Russia uh kind of
near to where the incident uh the actual
incident took place and kind of
specifically choosing relatively known
actors so that the movie would have that
much more kind of like verisimilitude
much like The Blair Witch Project you
know what I mean
um and because in the context of the
story
the characters are actually professional
filmmakers who are working on a
documentary uh the movie is actually
shot pretty nicely too like there
doesn't really there's not a lot of that
real amateurish like shaky cam [ __ ]
that like turns turns a lot of people
like off the found footage subgenre in
general so there isn't any of that well
there is a little bit but not much so
from what I could glean uh it does seem
like critical and audience reactions to
this movie seem to be like pretty mixed
um leaning toward the negative
um the main sticking points seem to be
that uh you know the lack of originality
um it's deviance from the actual mystery
that it's based on uh the unlikability
of the characters and the outlandishness
of the final twist now I will concede to
all of these criticisms and I even agree
with them to some extent but I will say
again that this is actually like a
perfectly watchable film and was
actually quite a bit better than a lot
of other found footage movies that I've
seen now I will say the twist ending is
kinda out there for sure
but in spite of that I actually kind of
dug it
um though I can totally see why some
people might um think that it was stupid
or even maybe uh disrespectful to the
actual people who died in the incident
but I didn't mind it all that much so I
feel like everybody who would actually
be watching this uh would probably
already know what the diatlov pass
incident is but in case you don't I'll
just give like a little little very very
brief summary of what happened so back
in 1959 uh there was a group of nine
very experienced uh Soviet hikers and
they died in the northern you're all
mountains under somewhat mysterious
circumstances like at some point on the
night of February 1st 1959 the hikers
seem to have cut their way out of their
tent and like ran out into these
Sub-Zero temperatures like in the middle
of the night wearing like pretty
inadequate uh clothing like for the
weather you know what I mean like they
were just in their jammies or whatever
um all of them were subsequently found
dead now six of them had died of
hypothermia which you know is what you
would expect but strangely the other
three were actually found to have died
of some kind of physical trauma like one
had a busted up skull and like one had
like all this stuff in his chest and
things like that
so theories about what killed these
hikers
uh range all over the map from you know
kind of reasonable hypothesis like it
was an avalanche or maybe an animal
attack or something like that
um then you got kind of like more
conspiratorial stuff like a military
cover-up like maybe they were somewhere
they weren't supposed to be uh two they
kind of like a little bit more
incredible or out there like aliens or
like attacked by a yeti or something
like that although I'm gonna come down
on the side of uh there's probably some
really mundane explanation like for you
know why these people died so tragically
um the unusual little details about the
case have you know obviously sparked a
lot of people's imaginations for decades
since it happened and the incident is a
very popular topic of discussion and
speculation like in various weirder
Unsolved Mysteries areas of the internet
so making a fictional film based on the
incident seemed like pretty inevitable
and I'm sure this isn't the only one now
I will note though that Devil's Pass
isn't technical based on the direct
incident itself in other words it's not
set in 1959 and it's not following the
actual hikers who died it's actually set
in the present day
and it centers around as I mentioned
earlier this small group of filmmakers
who are shooting a documentary about the
real occurrence and are traveling to the
area where it took place in order to
kind of like retrace the hiker's
footsteps and maybe try to get a handle
on what happened to them so our two main
characters are Holly and Jensen who are
co-directing the documentary now Holly
seems I mean she just basically seems
like she's really intrigued by the case
as a whole and always has been and is
really really curious to visit the site
where it occurred the somewhat
insufferable Jensen is one of those very
smug well actually [ __ ] who
very condescendingly tells Holly
everything she knows about the diatlov
past incident is wrong wrong like he's
watching like uh footage that they shot
of like some psychologist or something
like that it was like talking about uh
you know maybe what happened there and
he's just like scoffing though that's
not right that's ridiculous and stuff
like that so I will say that even though
Jensen does end up being correct like in
the universe of this movie in any case
uh that doesn't make his character any
less punchable so the rest of the gang
consists of JP and Andy who are like the
expert mountain climbers that they're
taking along and Denise who is the sound
engineer so after some kind of like
brief establishing stuff that's taking
place on the college campus where they
all go to college obviously and some
preliminary footage from that they
supposedly shot like of this documentary
that they're making that kind of gets
the audience up to speed on the broad
outlines of the actual diatlov uh pass
case for those that are unfamiliar with
it uh after that like the group heads
out to Russia so the first thing they do
when they get there is they go to this
mental health facility to talk to the
sole surviving member of the original
group of hikers this character who you
only kind of see from afar like in a
window was based on a real life guy uh
named Yuri Udin and he was actually
supposed to accompany the diatlov group
back in 1959 but he had to opt out like
pretty shortly into the journey because
he had like some health issues now in
the movie The filmmakers try to talk to
the guy like they go to the hospital but
a bunch of orderlies come out and are
just like you can't film here get away
from here the the dude's dead like piss
off you know what I mean
but as they're leaving this old man like
comes to a second floor wind floor
window and like holds up this cardboard
sign that has something written on it in
Russian
um but none of the filmmakers can
actually read it and then like the
orderlies kind of like drag him away so
obviously there's some kind of like
cover-up or something going on because
this is obviously the person that they
wanted to talk to and like the orderly
said that he was dead so later on while
they're having a drink in a bar like
after this kind of disappointing first
day that they had the gang meet this
nice fellow named Sergey who offers them
all a ride in his truck like to the base
of the mountain since I guess there's
like no train that goes out there
so one of the group actually asks Sergey
to translate the phrase that was written
on the sign that the old man showed them
and Sergey tells them it means stay away
not real encouraging obviously uh but
the gang decides they're gonna Forge
ahead anyhow now it so happens that
Sergey is going to see his elderly Aunt
who coincidentally not only lives right
nearer to where the filmmakers are going
but was also on the search team who
found the original hikers like back in
1959 now she tells them a very
interesting uh piece of information she
said that she saw 11 bodies not the
official nine and that the extra two
bodies that she saw were kind of
situated away from the others looked
very strange and were accompanied by
what she called a machine now remember
this little detail from later because it
will play into the twist at the end in a
somewhat kind of clever way so once the
group get up into the mountains uh you
get kind of like the expected camping
scenes interpersonal dramas between you
know some of the characters like hooking
up and [ __ ] like that so forth most of
which that's fine but not really what
you paid to say like to be to be fair uh
now to the movie's credit though um it
weird [ __ ] does start happening like
pretty quickly like one morning for
example the filmmakers wake up and they
find a series of large footprints in the
snow made by someone or something uh
walking in bare feet which you know if
you weren't aware is a very unwise thing
to be doing when it's like [ __ ] 15
degrees below zero and everything is
covered with snow
so Holly the main person is kind of like
freaked out but everybody else thinks
that she just faked some Yeti [ __ ] like
for her movie so she could film it um
even though she's like uh duh I wouldn't
do that but they're just like yeah
whatever like tell us another one so the
gang follow these Footprints uh even
though they think they're fake uh to
this weather station nearby that's been
all like kind of Torn To Hell and in the
weather station like this little box or
whatever they find an object which
appears to be a severed tongue possibly
human they're not really sure
there's also the unsettling fact that
their GPS devices which are supposed to
be like infallible and which the guys
that I even use this at the Himalayas
like it was fine uh but the GPS's are
all screwed up and they actually seem to
reach the diatlov pass way earlier than
should have been possible and then at
some stage there's like an avalanche
that kills one member of the team
and uh also they kind of get shot at by
two guys who just kind of like wander
out of nowhere and later on two of the
gang stumble across what appears to be a
hidden door beneath the snow which leads
into kind of like this bunker type
situation which is carved into the
mountain now I don't necessarily want to
spoil exactly what the explanation for
what the original diatlov pass incident
is purported to be at least in the
context of this movie but I will reveal
that it involves
creatures of some description uh as well
as kind of like a conspiracy slash
science fiction element that name checks
The Philadelphia Experiment so if that
gives you an idea of like which
direction it's heading in then you know
what I mean if you know what the
Philadelphia Experiment is so now some
reviewers uh that I read like thought
this plot twist was too far out there
but I actually didn't really mind it um
now I will admit that it's really not
all that believable and and I think that
one of the things that kind of hinders
the believability somewhat is like the
CGI toward the end like looks so video
game-like and I think if it maybe if it
had been better CGI or something like it
would have been a little bit more easy
to swallow perhaps but you know I'm not
going to get to I'm not gonna [ __ ] on
the movie too hard about that because I
mean really it's just like an
entertaining flick at the end of the day
it's not meant to be
um you know a creepy like realistic
examination of what actually happened to
the real hikers like back in the 50s
which would actually probably make a
good movie but if you're gonna go that
route you might as well just make a
documentary you know what I'm saying
um now this movie I'm gonna say it's not
scary at all like I didn't find it scary
um but it like I said it does have an
interesting premise
um you know based on the actual mystery
kind of and after you watch it you'll
probably realize that
clues about the resolution were kind of
peppered into the film like all
throughout the run time that you might
not have even noticed like while you
were watching it at first so like only
in retrospect does some of this stuff
make sense which like I said I thought
was like pretty clever so I mean if you
like found footage movies generally and
are interested in seeing a story that's
somewhat based on a real mysterious case
then you know you might get a kick out
of it but don't expect it to be giving
you like a plausible scenario for what
may have actually happened to those
people because this is like not it on
the other hand if you don't like found
footage then I'm gonna say that Devil's
Pass isn't really like original or
noteworthy enough to like change your
mind or like say oh you should make an
exception in this regard
um I will admit that it is far better
shot than many found footage movies
because like I said in the context of
the movie It's supposed to be like
professionally shot so it doesn't look
like all Spazzy and [ __ ] like that I
mean it's not overall it's not like
fantastic but I did have like a decent
time with it I thought it was
entertaining it's not boring or anything
like that and the twist at the end and I
always like when this happens like the
twist at the end kind of made me
reassess the film as a whole and I kind
of appreciated it a great deal more like
after the twist happened because then I
could go back and go oh that's what they
were talking about with this that and
the other thing and like I said then I
kind of went back and like I noticed
like all these little clues that were in
there which I thought was kind of neat
so have you seen Devil's Pass or have
you seen another movie because I'm sure
there's more than one uh that's based on
the diatlov pass incident and what did
you think about it or them let me know
in the comments and that will do it for
this flickers of fear I'll see you guys
again on the next one bye oh
[Music]
my God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you